die schweiz streitet über ein stück
stoff eine rechtspopulistische
initiative hat das burkaverbot zum
volksentscheid gebracht und es geschafft
die schweiz zu spalten
wie konnte es so weit kommen sollte eine
frau nicht selbst entscheiden rissen
tragen da in diesem fall
ich würds mir den burka oder den nikab
instrumentalisiert und wenn ja mit
welchem ziel
darüber möchte ich mit den menschen
sprechen willkommen zu einer neuen folge
von trending mein name ist coco ticke
leser muss ebony und ich bin gerade hier
in der schweiz
hier zeigt sich wie emotional die
diskussion um die verschleierung
muslimischer frauen mittlerweile
geworden ist ich möchte wissen worum
geht es wirklich helvetiaplatz in zürich
hunderte menschen demonstrieren für den
feministischen kampf ich bin auf der
suche nach menschen für die die
verteilungsdebatte ein thema ist
[Applaus]
ich treffe auf eine gruppe frauen von
ihnen möchte ich wissen was sie über die
aktuelle debatte denken wieso seid ihr
heute hier plötzlich werden wir
unterbrochen und kontrolliert eine
kontrolle aus als die polizisten
verlangen meinen ausweis
ich versuche ihnen zu erklären dass sich
journalisten bin und eine reportage über
das verhüllungsverbot drehe ich bekomme
einen platzverweis
ich kann es immer noch nicht glauben
dass ich jetzt gerade da weg geben
musste weil wir eigentlich nichts
gemacht haben also wir standen da in
dieser kleinen tiere gruppe und ja jetzt
treffe ich anna und asli und ich hoffe
dass wir irgendwo miteinander sprechen
können
[Musik]
lilianas land ist muslimin setzt sich
für gleichstellung mit dem verein wo man
ein besonders in der arbeitswelt aller
rosenwasser ist journalistin und nutzt
ihre reichweite auf instagram gegen das
verhüllungsverbot sie kämpft für alle
geschlechter und schreibt texte darüber
es ist noch ein tag bis zum
volksentscheid wie aufgeheizt die
stimmung ist wie schnell alles
eskalieren kann werde ich später selbst
erfahren die menschen hier demonstrieren
gegen das patriarchat
viele fühlen sich durch die burka
kampagne vereint viele meinen dass wenn
die initiative angenommen wird die
frauen befreit sind und darum geht es
nicht man befreit frauen nicht indem man
ihnen eine kleine vorschrift macht diese
initiative wurde gestaltet von 60 weißen
sehr stark rechten männer und zwar nicht
mit dem ziel irgendwem zu befreien aber
durchaus mit dem vorwand die armen
muslimen zu befreien
das leben fühlt sich die ganze debatte
für mich sehr ermüdend und anstrengend
an weil ich dem wirklich auch sehr nahe
stehe und mich damit die letzten wochen
intensiv befasst habe und es geht nicht
einfach so an ihr bereit
die demo ist nicht gemeint aber wir
sollten langsam gehen weil wir werden
hier gerade so eingekesselt die polizei
macht sich bereit die kundgebung
aufzulösen
auf einmal liegt eine spannung
investiert aber dazu gleich mehr
bei der volksabstimmung in der schweiz
geht es vor allem um religiöse
verschleierungen wie burka und nikab
lanciert hat die volksabstimmung das
egerkinger komitee ein islamkritischer
verein der der rechtskonservativen svp
nahe steht mit dem verhüllungsverbot
wollen sie extremismus und die
islamisierung der schweiz stoppen
die zahl der frauen die in der schweiz
regelmässig mit niqab unterwegs sind
wird gerade mal auf knapp 40 geschätzt
das kopftuch oder auch app genannt ist
von geplanten verhüllungsverbot nicht
betroffen
mir ist es wichtig nicht nur über die
nikab trägerinnen zu sprechen sondern
auch mit die stimmung in der schweiz ist
angespannt ich bekomme nur absagen auf
instagram entdecke ich schließlich
valentina weiß sie ist schweizerin um
mit 30 jahren zum islam konvertiert kurz
vor der volksabstimmung hat sie
tatsächlich das land verlassen und ist
nach ägypten gereist um dort das
ergebnis abzuwarten da ich für den
abstimmungskampf einige interviews hatte
habe ich mich hier ein bisschen
eingerichtet ein bisschen provisorisch
aber hier habe ich meine interviews
gehalten
du bist noch durch sind wegen
wahrscheinlich wegen wir wegen der
abstellung ja genau genau das ist
ehrlich sagen ich bekommen momentan so
viele hartz nachrichten von wegen
bis jetzt weg und ich werde keiner
vermissen in der schweiz wo ich mir
manchmal denke ich genau wegen solchen
nachrichten würde ich am liebsten den
nächsten flieger steigen und in die
schweiz fliegen und sagen so geht so
einfach wäre der mich nicht los aber
momentan ist es mir einfach zu
gefährlich
ich muss da schon sagen wenn ich das mit
meiner tochter unterwegs wäre und ich
habe sie hat meistens in der frage was
für mich am einfachsten ist was ich
hätte da ich hätte da echt angst und
wenn jetzt jemand einfach so zu dir
sagen würde valentina nimm doch den
niqab einfach wieder ab dann könntest du
wieder zurück in die schweiz kommen
wurde mir auch schon gesagt wenn man
zwar angezogen hat und man fühlt sich
wohl damit warum sollte man dann das
ausziehen oder sich verändern
ich bin das beste beispiel oder ich rede
aus meiner eigenen erfahrung dass ich es
freiwillig trage ich war mit meinem mann
nicht verheiratet als ich das kopftuch
angezogen habe und ich habe mich auch
freiwillig und unabhängig von ihm für
den niqab entschieden ich kann es
verstehen dass frauen vielleicht sagen
hey der islam
der mann hat so viele rechte und und und
und das frauen vielleicht mit dem nicht
klar kommen aber das ist dann ihre sache
ich komme vielleicht mit anderen sachen
auch nicht klar was sie jetzt in ihrem
leben machen aber ich habe mich dafür
entschieden und für mich stimmt das so
und du bleibst jetzt in ägypten und
ihren eltern sind in der schweiz
unsere business mit seinem mann ägyptens
und bleibst und jetzt kannst du einfach
erst mal seine eltern nicht sehen außer
wenn sie sich in ägypten besuchen kommen
ja genau das ist jetzt nun sind ja nicht
nur meine eltern ich habe auch
geschwister ich habe nerven und nichten
ich habe freunde und deshalb schon hart
wenn man ihn nicht mehr sehen
der nikab ist für valentina eine
freiwillige entscheidung und teil ihrer
identität
ich werde später übrigens noch mit
seiner frau sprechen die eine ganz
andere geschichte zu erzählen
ich frage mich was bewirkt so ein verbot
überhaupt die soziologin stpo forscht
seit über 20 jahren zu der
vollverschleierung von muslimischen
frauen und lebt in frankreich
hier ist die vollverschleierung seit
2011 im öffentlichen raum verboten
agnes defeo sagt anstatt den cup zu
verbieten sollte man versuchen zu
verstehen warum diese frauen ihr gesicht
verhüllen möchten
heute wird in die kap von der zweiten
und dritten generation wieder getragen
es handelt sich dabei um frauen die in
frankreich geboren sind und die dem
niqab nun gerade deshalb tragen weil
ihre mütter sich zu sehr angepasst haben
denn sie sind so französisch geworden
dass sie ihre muslimische identität
verdrängt haben diese jungen frauen
fordern ihre muslimische identität nun
auf eine sehr herausfordernde art und
weise wieder ein
sie wollen der gesellschaft zeigen und
beweisen dass sie muslimischer sind als
ihre mütter
es ist also keineswegs ein symbol der
rückständigkeit würde ein gesetz den
frauen helfen
wie auch immer die frauen haben ihre
gründe ist zu tragen
und tatsächlich wird das gesetz ihnen
nicht helfen da sie angst vor der
polizei haben
und vor allem werden sie angst vor den
schweizer bürger innen haben die sie oft
quälen beleidigen angreifen
sie werden so noch häufiger opfer sein
das ironische an der durchsetzung
solcher verbote ist dass viele argumente
gefunden werden die vermeintlich belegen
dass dies die frauen befreit aber
eigentlich passiert das gegenteil denn
ein verbot macht die frauen
verletzlicher und sorgt für einen noch
schwächeren stand in der gesellschaft
frauen die eine vollverschleierung
tragen werden so nur noch mehr probleme
haben als bisher
es passiert also genau das gegenteil und
das ist wirklich absurd
ich habe keine worte die hat
sind um die dummheit auszudrücken die
diese art von gesetzentwurf darstellen
kann
bei meinen recherchen in der instagram
babbel die gegen das verhüllungsverbot
ist entdecke ich den instituten kanal
der farm frauen hier solidarisieren sich
schweizerinnen und sagen nein zur
bürgerinitiative fatima afrika ist ein
von ihm geboren ist fatima in sri lanka
als dreijährige kam sie mit ihren eltern
in die schweiz
heute arbeitet sie in einer werbeagentur
[Musik]
umwelt und trotzdem wird auf uns mit dem
finger gezeigt ist ein finger punkten
gegen die muslimische bevölkerung
umgesehen von ihr seiten und dann
willkommen
wenn ihr eigentlich nicht auffällt wenn
ihr wenn ihr nicht sichtbar sein und
wenn ihr sicher seid dann haben wir ein
problem mit euch sei das mit kopftüchern
am arbeitsplatz je nachdem
oder auch an hochschulen für mich ist es
heute noch sehr spannend zu sehen
deshalb schon noch viel ungewissheit zu
dem thema da ist und ob diese
ungewissheit haut auch vorurteile und
diese vorurteile führen dann eigentlich
zu angst und die svp hat das egerkinger
komitee über diese initiative lanciert
hat
arbeitet genau mit dieser angst machen
quasi symbol politik auf dem rücken
muslimen
heute ist ein wichtiger tag für sie
fatima hat ein interview mit dem
schweizer fernsehen thema das
verhüllungsverbot ich gehe davon aus es
sei ja was eigentlich
ich habe mich und so darf war mental
vorbereitet damit ich dann nicht
gestresst bin ich darf live mit dabei
sein wenn sie bei der tv aufzeichnung
auf eine person trifft die für das
verhüllungsverbot ist
fátima trifft oft sind rechtsanwalt
emrah erkennen beide machen ihren
standpunkt klar was sie über das
verhüllungsverbot denken verärgern des
pro verhüllungsverbot
deswegen werde ich mit ihm auch gleich
noch mal sprechen weil es natürlich
total interessant ist wieso
merken sagt er kämpft aktiv seit 1992
gegen die rechtskonservative svp aber
bei diesem thema gibt es für ihn keine
andere antwort aus prinzipiellen gründen
weil ich der ansicht bin dass grenzen
gesetzt werden müssen und dass die
vollverschleierung in der schweiz
eigentlich nichts verloren hat also ich
wollte der existenz der
vollverschleierung jede
daseinsberechtigung entziehen damit dass
hier nicht mehr möglich wird sollte eine
frau nicht selbst entscheiden was sie
tragen darf in diesem fall nein das ist
nicht ihr entscheid weil diese diese
kleidung hat eine spezifische bedeutung
und diese vollverschleierung hat eine
radikale bedeutung eine ziemlich extreme
radikale bedeutung die frau so
vollständig unsichtbar gemacht werden
ihre persönlichkeit so vollständig
verschwinden und es ist ein derart
krasse persönlichkeit verzicht dass das
vergleichbar ist mit der selbst für
sklaven und ich selbst für sklaven ist
verboten
das ist ethisch nicht zulässig und ist
dann für sie eine europäerin die einen
niqab trägt eine radikale islamisten auf
jähnichen
es ist wie schluss die polarisierende
stimmung die aktuell durch die debatte
in der schweiz geführt wird
ich war heute ganz nach es ist der tag
der abstimmung und es gibt schon einen
trend für das verhüllungsverbot
mich ist es aber auch ganz klar ein
zeichen dass wir noch das 4 muslime noch
mehr in die öffentlichkeit kommen müssen
wir müssen mehr zeigen dass wir
integriert sind dass wir ein teil der
schweiz und dass wir unsere daily life
eigentlich hier meisten mit bravour und
vollkommen ihnen fliegen und alles und
wie überhaupt nicht so aussehen wie
diese frauen auf diesen wirklich
schrecklichen plakaten der svp
das müssen wir halt noch weiter daran
arbeiten langsam verstehe ich wie
komplex die verteilungsdebatte ist und
dass sie sich nicht einfach mit einer
politischen zugehörigkeit erklären lässt
die meinungen sind selbst innerhalb der
verschiedenen gruppierungen gespalten
ich muss sagen seitdem in zürich es war
immer sehr emotional
kann mir ein blogger
bin gespannt auf das ergebnis der
abstimmung
sobald wir eine frau mit kopftuch sehen
stecken wie sie oft in eine schublade
verbinden das stück stoff mit
unterdrückung und rückständigkeit
ich frage mich woher dieser gedanke
kommt hansa lammert ist islam und
religionswissenschaftlerin am zürcher
institut für interreligiösen dialog und
antworten für mich wir haben ein
bestimmtes bild von einem muslimischen
mann von einem muslimischen frau und
diese bilder fußen vor allem in kolonial
ansatz mann ist hat natürlich auch mit
diesem kolonial anspruch inländer rhein
gelaufen und hat bestimmt was ist enorm
und enorm
alles was von dieser norm dieser
vermeintlichen abgewichen ist war
primitiv oder war zurückgeblieben und
man hat einfach ein bestimmte ausdruck
für moderne gefunden und alles was davon
abweicht bis heute gilt als nicht in
ordnung ganz so ganz einfaches beispiel
wenn ich einen der bildreihe in wünschen
damit ist traditionsbewusst dann bin ich
feiere ich die kultur aber wenn ich eben
ein kopftuch trage kommt gleich die
bewertung dass es ja nicht mehr moderne
seien mit ins spiel
wir haben jetzt auch lange sie sind
begriff alter weißer mann gehabt und
daran haben sich sehr viele sehr schnell
gestört weil sie zum ersten mal
kategorisierte sind
die macher der volksabstimmung pro
burka-verbot spielen in ihrer kampagne
mit dieser angst vor dem vermeintlich
fremden die plakate auf den frauen niqab
gezeigt werden vermitteln den eindruck
sie sind eine gefahr
zurück zur demonstration in zürich wir
sind inzwischen komplett von polizisten
eingekesselt
hat uns gerade darüber informiert dass
hier nichts tun objekt wird keine form
der konnten wir wollen nur noch raus
so besagt es geschafft dann gehen wir
aus okay geben wir aus oder sie hören
nach der schnell weg hier
und dann sind wir nur noch gebannt
es war wirklich ein zaun gesprungen
und frauen sind geräten laufen
ich weiß nicht wann ich das letzte mal
man ebenso angst gehabt haben
ich habe wirklich gerade angst gehabt ja
ihre schwester haben sie mitgenommen
diese schwester haben sie mit am abend
entdeckte ich auf instagram was offenbar
kurz nachdem wir über den zaun
geklettert so passiert ist
die demo ist komplett aus dem ruder
gelaufen ich bin geschockt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im netz sind die fronten nicht weniger
verhärtet in dieser debatte scheint es
für viele nur schwarz und weiß zu geben
ich entdecke den worldcup day gegründet
hat ihnen das mag an
sie kam mit elf jahren aus bangladesch
nach new york und fühlte sich als hit up
trägerin diskriminiert mit dem tag will
sie das verständnis für das tragen des
jobs in nicht muslimischen ländern
fördern
einige frauen sehen darin im home and
andere thematisierung von unterdrückung
kritikerin kern genau diesen ersten
februar zu noah job day um eine davon
ist jasmin mohammed der neue job day ist
eine gegenbewegung für frauen die
gezwungen werden sich zu verschleiern
und davon frei sein möchten einen frohen
naughty dog day melli damen möge dir
alle dem wind in euren haaren und die
sonne auf euren wangen spüren und all
das tun was ihr tun wollt und das tragen
was ihr tragen wollte wenn ihr jetzt
tragen wird ich habe von dem workshop
day gehört da wusste ich nicht mal dass
es den gibt und an dem tag als ich
diesen world.de entdeckt habe war ich so
deprimiert ich konnte es kaum glauben
da waren so viele frauen dabei die ich
bewundere wie er kann michelle obama all
diese leute haben über diesen world
title getwittert und ihn gefeiert
das hat mir das herz gebrochen
also ich würde niemals eine frau darum
bitten ihr kopftuch abzunehmen
deswegen gibt es den oecd für diejenigen
die sich bereits dafür entschieden haben
es abzunehmen
für frauen die mit belästigung und ärger
in ihrem eigenen communitys zu tun haben
von ihren familien und deren
gesellschaften als ich damit anfing
hatte ich keine ahnung was für eine
reaktion folgen würde
wir haben so unglaublich viele bilder
videos und posts von frauen aus der
ganzen welt bekommt diesen dankbar waren
dass ihre stunden endlich gehört wurden
jasmin wuchs in kanada in einem
radikalislamischen haushalt auf mit neun
jahren musste sie ein kopftuch tragen
später wurde sie zu einer ehe mit einem
mitglied von al-qaida gezwungen und
musste fünf jahre lang ein niqab tragen
das alles passierte in kanada sie
bezeichnet sich heute als ex muslime
ich hätte so ein niqab das sogar meine
augen verdeckt hatte man konnte nicht
mal meine augen sehen weil er sagte
seine augen sind auch eine sünde
er meinte es ist weil du so schön ist
deine augen sind so wunderschön deswegen
müssen wir sicher bergen die sachen die
ihr das auf eine art mit weise dass du
dich nicht so gut wären kannst es ist so
und menschlich und du hast das gefühl
die verrotte ist unter dieser bedeckung
weißt du dass es wie ein totenhemd damit
bedeckt man eigentlich leute wenn sie
tot sind und nicht wenn sie noch atmen
meine reise in der schweiz ist zu ende
und das ergebnis der volksabstimmung ist
bekannt 51,2 prozent der schweizerinnen
votieren für das verhüllungsverbot ein
knappes ergebnis knapp 40 frauen dürfen
nun kein weg mehr tragen und auch für
viele andere muslimen bleibt etwas
zurück
wenn ich solche bedrohlichen plakate
oder angst schüren plakate sehe dann
denke ich ist schon der gedanke dahinter
dass sie angst machen wollen und ich
finde es an dieser stelle nicht okay das
verhüllte frauen für diese plakate
missbraucht werden weil das ist nicht
okay
und das macht angst und das führt zu
falschen gedanken also feminismus und
islam passt es dann eigentlich für euch
zusammen
ja ja ja definitiv
als muslimin kann das sagen dass für
meniskus und der islam das passt ja
interessant ich war vier tage in der
schweiz und ganz ehrlich ich habe nicht
gedacht dass es so intensiv wird viele
starke perspektiven mit
unterschiedlichen meinungen in den
letzten tagen konnte ich wirklich schöne
eindrücke sammeln
ich bin keine muslimin aber ich habe
gelernt wie komplex der islam ist und
dass es nicht den islam gibt als eine
religion die von allen gleich ausgelebt
wird und wenn man das verstanden hat
dann versteht man auch die verschiedenen
perspektiven und wie verschiedene
muslimische menschen ihre religion
ausleben was sagt ihr geht es bei
solchen debatten wirklich um die rechte
der frauen schreibt es mir gerne in die
kommentare